you cannot have any bad days because
those fans don't know what you're going
through you might have a family problem
you might you maybe maybe you broke up
with your girlfriend or you're having
problem at home uh maybe you're getting
divorced or maybe you're about to have a
kid so you
not every day your mind is with
basketball
but the fans see that and they're like
we are paying thousands of dollars to
watch you play so we're like it was like
a circus you know it was literally like
a circus and we cannot have any bad days
um
so how you come
I think the one thing that we always did
was just every
after game we're just sitting down in a
locker room and if someone had a bad day
if someone missed like a very important
shot if uh
if someone doesn't feel like themselves
who are sitting down in a locker room
and and say okay we are family we
whatever is whatever is happening let's
talk in a locker room and whatever
happens in a locker room stays in a
locker room you know maybe we're gonna
fight maybe we were gonna talk maybe we
were gonna discuss this that but it's
not gonna come out of this Locker
um
so that made all of us feel so much
better I'm like okay like you know some
people I missed the game-winning shot
the whole city might hate me you know no
uh the whole media is gonna destroy me
tomorrow morning but at least I have my
teammates back yeah you know and we're
we always have this strategy if one of
this media that will come after us we're
going to protect each other yeah you
know because media media laws drop so
they're gonna be like well this player
didn't pass you the ball you could have
just dumped the ball are you mad at him
and if you say anything
that my and inside you are Madison of
course
we could have win the game yeah but if
you cannot even if you like you like
maybe you're like even if you roll your
eyes yeah I promise you they take a
screenshot of that right and the next
day oh Ennis doesn't like his teammates
yeah so that's why athletes when they
get asked questions by the media it's
always the same you know oh I'm I love
my teammates I would just need to work
hard and we'll get the next one but
that's not what we talk in a lot
obviously the locker room you're like
dude I was open why didn't you pass me
the ball right or like what's going on
do you have a problem yeah so we were
trying to solve every problem in a
locker room and when we got out of this
locker room we're all good and we've
we've talked about you know the pressure
but what's probably even more difficult
and this is how do you deal with success
how do you deal from going from a
regular background to all of a sudden
being a young kid who is surrounded by
wealth adulation Fame women I mean if
that had happened to me when I was 20
I'd be in rehab 19 19. even worse to
your teenager I mean
um so that's why MBA had this like
programs because like rookie transition
program you know so um
whenever you enter the league you go to
these programs and the older or retired
players comes and gives you their
experience that what happened throughout
their career and some of the things that
you hear is just unbelievable because
think about this you're 19 years old
you're just getting drafted the whole
world is talking about you they're
giving you millions of dollars and
everywhere you go you don't have to pay
for anything you eat free food you shop
free you do everything for free you know
and you literally become a huge
celebrity and now with all the social
media and everything you have a huge
influence and you can Inspire so many
people but sometimes like players don't
know what to do with all this Fame all
this money you know so that's why they
they go to clubs and they go to bars and
they find 10 20 girlfriends and it just
boom did you do any of that no because I
had a really good team around me really
good team around me and they always
protected me you know because I mean
Coming to America coming to America my
family raised me really well and they
were like you know I'm obviously because
of my faith because I'm a Muslim I'm not
allowed to drink I'm not allowed to
really go out I'm allowed to do certain
things that my teams my teammates were
doing it you know so that really
protected me but other than that I'm you
know I had a I think average NBA players
career is four years wow yeah because
they come into the league boom clubs
girls drinks this and that and they're
gone
well yeah so
it was your faith that kept you on the
straight and narrow but I guess the
question is as well it's just
there must have been a part of you that
was tempted there must have been a part
of you where you just thought to
yourself
you know you know look we're all men
we're all human there must have been a
couple of ladies when you're like
I've worked really hard this week it is
it was it is so crazy because everywhere
we go they were waiting for us we go to
hotels they're waiting at the lobby we
go to a game they're waiting we go to a
restaurant we go to mall they know our
schedule obviously the schedule was out
before the season so every
um
City we go
for somehow they already know the hotel
we're staying so it's like we're going
back you go down the lobby and there are
like
right once the Instagram came so they
already know our schedule you know so
before we go to this series they were
already having us I said hey you know
you're coming to our city let's hang out
and it was literally like a menu you
just literally just scroll it down okay
I did not do this I'm just saying like
yeah of course people who did it it was
like a minute you just go down you're
like I want a blunt today I want a
brunette today I want this I want that
you could literally just pick or one two
maybe more you know so uh that's why a
lot of the players were just losing
focus because of all that yeah you know
they thought that this is going to last
forever
you know but
they were just
going out and partying all night and
coming to the game the next day they
can't even walk because they're Angora
from last night you know I had a lot of
teammates I'm like we had a game so we
usually go to the city the night before
and then in the morning we have practice
and then at time we play basketball we
play the game I had a lot of teammates
even in the morning
before the practice they were like they
could hardly walk so I'm like how are
you gonna go out there and play
basketball compete against these guys
like Kobe LeBron or Kevin Garnett Dirk
Nowitzki Paul Gasol and they're like
well I'll be fine I'll take a nap
he would end up getting hurt because his
body was just not ready for that for 11.
and also it makes it more challenging
particularly if you come like a lot of
these guys from very poor backgrounds
where you have nothing and then it's not
like you go into business and gradually
you build yourself up and you're
starting to make it's zero to a hundred
miles an hour that's why you know like
you ask so many people a lot of the NBA
players goes Brock right after the
career because you know when you come
from like you know poor families and
your first contract is like 20 million
dollar what do you want to do you want
to show off right so you want to buy
your friend a car you want to buy your
other friend a house you want to buy
another friend a car and these are like
really expensive cars and homes so you
really want to you you're really trying
to take care of your whole street or
your whole neighborhood you know and you
go out there and buy this like a hundred
thousand dollars or juries or watches
and stuff which you don't even need you
know so they always think that okay
money is going to come
forever but no the only when you get
hurt you're done you know if you don't
take care of yourself
if you have like an injury prawn then
the plays on the teams are not going to
sign you
what was the big thing that you bought
with my with my first
um
with my first Contact I literally took
my
teammates or Pizza Hut
it's a Pizza Hut
and we had a we had a blast we had so
much fun and it was like oh you can eat
too so you were just like killing it
yeah you know but I'm trying to think I
really didn't buy anything like house
car nothing what nothing really nothing
I'm as you see I'm a very simple very
simple person I mean I was like the one
thing I've always done I was just
donating a lot of money to some of the
families out there especially in Turkey
um because I'm sure you guys know this
situation over there yeah well we'll
talk about it we'll talk about it yeah
but um but other than that I didn't
really buy anything crazy
foreign